hey guys what's up I'm Alana and welcome
to my channel today I'm making a video
in the strangest location that I think
I've ever made a video in which is a
Seattle Airport it's also really strange
I had to fly from San Francisco to
Seattle and then back to San Francisco
and then to Sydney Australia because
United her a terrible a-line they
wouldn't let me just get on the plane in
San Francisco and for whatever reason it
was like seven hundred dollars cheaper
if I booked the flight from Seattle so I
had to go San Francisco Seattle San
Francisco meaning it's taking me like
three days and full separate flights to
get home it's insane but here we are and
very tired and very sick but today I'm
about the highlights
so first up obviously we had kids for
fall I made a video about this a little
while ago but my thoughts after
finishing the game change like quite a
bit from that video I'm gonna try not to
repeat myself though so let's turn to
the grief I think multiplayer is amazing
I think the eSports mode is fantastic
and addictive there maybe a little bit
too long to play casually I feel like in
actual competitive environments it's
about the right length but it's the best
of 14 so when you're just playing at
home that is a pretty long amount of
time depending on how quickly you win or
lose sudden matches what is great but
after playing it I think there are some
maps that it just doesn't want going
there are some that it's really
challenging on and some where you really
only have one obvious vantage points and
things are kind of fed through awkwardly
so it doesn't really work out that well
my initial complaints about the story
with that it was not very funny and
didn't feel all that different and I
still think up to finishing the whole
game it doesn't feel all that different
and they played it a little bit safe I
don't care
from act 3.5 onwards I really really
liked it you kid got funny and I started
actually awful things and the end of the
games so good there's this weird thing
that games do a lot where to create a
sense of climax they actually just make
things very very hard and it's hard but
that doesn't mean that it's a good
climax it's just hard Gears of War 4 has
one of the most fun and
that I think that I played on new gen
consoles if not the most fun the one
thing that I missed the most that I wish
we had some off is like bazookas and the
effects that they had and how scared I
wasn't those so she was a little scarier
next up was battlefield one I haven't
played that online but I have played
through I think three of the five
campaign and I like them a lot I don't
know if it's because I'm Australian and
because it's part of Australian history
that Philip II was a huge thing but that
one was my favorite one I think that
it's mostly because they present you
with characters that you have to get to
know in a very very small amount of time
and even in the two hours or less that I
spent with those characters I really
cared about them the voice acting is
really good the script is really good
and I feel like that just the right
length to get you invested but to no
doubt stay and welcome will feel like
they dragged on a tall bottle so 1922 in
Vietnam with some of the first two games
that I ever played online and I played
quite a bit of them but I haven't really
cared about any battlefield campaign
except the Bad Company 2
and I think this while it's not bad
company 2 and it's not really so what a
Bad Company 2 is the battlefield in for
the best campaigns for sure then of
course we had the Red Dead to trade off
this was unexpected I was a truck stop
the week before they announced Red Dead
- and I asked him about it I was like so
Red Dead nothing didn't say a word we
had no idea this was coming
then they sweep that [ __ ] image of
the bread with the company logo and
mannequins and got like a hundred
thousand retweets and favorites and it's
just it's just and it's just a company
logo with a red background like I I
can't think of anyone else who can
basically get away with a not telling
press or making any kind of press
release just tweeting and clocking image
everyone loses their minds but of course
we all suspected that Red Dead 2 was on
its way which is partly because the
studio down in San Diego who made red
wine I have not announced they've been
walking want anything so it was like
well yeah
probably working on that and it was like
commercials it was a commercial success
chance to an extent so it makes sense
that they would make a sequel I don't
really have a whole lot of thoughts on
the trailer except that it looks very
pretty though even before it was
announced every time we would talk about
read tattoo on one of the podcasts and
walk or something people would be like
actually it's red dead 3 sure it's
technically the third game with Red Dead
at the start of it but I think that this
is intended to be a lot more like Red
Dead Redemption
than like Red Dead Revolver is I mean it
was made by different studio anyway and
last but not least was the Nintendo
switch which was basically dropped on us
at the same way that Red Dead 2 was in
the same week Nintendo switch I
basically feel the same way about Red
Dead I don't have much to say I'm
interested in how the cartridges are
going to walk but for the most part
especially as someone who travels all
the time today they have 18 flights left
just in 2016 to take so it totally it
feels to me I think it's a cool thing
and I probably will buy it it's cheap
enough and also if it has a lot of
Nintendo titles on it because boy it
stands right now is like Nintendo has
most of my nostalgia from the 64 so if I
can use that suit the portable things
like a total to my nostalgia for the
past 20 years that's amazing that's it
for me today everyone I'm sorry
audio quality said I am in an airport in
the middle of international travel and
basically was making this video because
I have some time to kill and I think why
not do it here rather than do it when
I'm at home when I could be spending
time with families so I did have one
person donate after my last video person
who supported my channel again for those
of you who don't know that's basically
like a tip jaw on YouTube way you can
give money to your favorite creators if
you want to i think it's on my about
page and below some of my videos so
there really never works but this person
didn't leave a comment with their
donations so I can't thank you
personally
two--this person and everyone else has
done that and just to all of you who
watch my stuff guys thank you so much
it's the best but getting crazy close to
100,000 I think that I might get there
like late December or early January no
idea what to do but I'm thinking that I
might do like a live stream QA or
something like that
I'll figure something out thank you guys
so much for watching I will see you next
time
well